welcome to the rock alright not really
the same thing but the cash line works
Alcatraz alright so Alcatraz is a new
series and I started watching it so I
gotta tell you what I think about it
ultimately the premises in 1963 Alcatraz
was shut down and all the prisoners were
shipped off somewhere else or is that
really what happened no in this show
they tell us that the prisoners just
disappeared for one reason or another
and now all these prisoners have started
reappearing in the world at the same age
that they were in Alcatraz in 1963 when
they just vanished and what exactly
happened to them well no one knows I
mean were they sucked up by aliens were
they part of the 4400 I'm going with
that one don't know but now we have our
show and is the show good you know what
not really here's my problem with the
show Alcatraz all these prisoners
disappeared another reappearing and
that's all cool and dandy and intriguing
but after that you have a cop chicken
this one writer guy we're going around
and rounding up these Alcatraz prisoners
for sam neill from Jurassic Park but
that's pretty much what the show is
although there is an intriguing cloud
hanging over the show me where the
prisoners go why they're coming back why
are they the same age that they were
when they vanished that premise is kind
of in the background the main point of
the show is this cop chick in this
writer guy that go around and round up
these prisoners that is the point of the
show and I understand this is the
beginning the shows just setting itself
up they're gonna deal with the
intriguing aspects later on and that is
all fine and dandy but until they do I'm
just kind of bored here you go take
fringe for example before it was all big
and epic it started out episodic it was
the same kind of freak of the week thing
they had there one case that they had to
solve that week and the next week they
would have their next case they would
have to solve that week but it's still
dealt with some really cool fringe
science stuff you know there was this
guy that turned into a beast that wiped
out a plane there was this bus full of
people that was frozen in the solid that
was a gas turn into a solid that was
cool it was some really intriguing
Michael Crichton fringe style [ __ ] that
they were doing while they were setting
up the big picture for the show so far
in Alcatraz a cop chick and a writer guy
go around and round up these criminals
and the big selling point of the show is
from executive producer JJ Abrams but
he's just executive producer he didn't
create the show his job as executive
producer is to make sure that everyone
has what they need to make the show
happen but he has nothing to do with the
characters the plot of the writing he
was a creator of lost he was a creator
of Fringe he was even a creator on that
one undercover show that lasted like
eight and a Half Men
it's but not Alcatraz so now we don't
have to blend JJ Abrams's and JJ Abrams
fans don't have to defend the show
Alcatraz and then you have the whole
illogical side of it you know like Sam
Neill heads up this organization of now
for people whose job is to go and get
these Alcatraz criminals and the base of
their operations is in the bottom of
Alcatraz itself now I understand the
writers and creators of this show want
to keep Alcatraz in people's minds when
they're watching the show but why would
they put the super-secret base of
operations the Batcave itself in the
bottom of a tourist attraction that
makes no sense especially if you need to
go and get someone really fast well I
hope the boat goes fast enough that's
the stupid decision-making kind of [ __ ]
that people like Alan Grant from
Jurassic Park are going to get fired for
like the Secretary of Defense is going
to be like sorry that was a dumb [ __ ]
move you're going to have to work with
Krispy Kreme now because we can't have
that going on here we need smart people
working for the government which would
officially be a first in the end I
wasn't really crazy about Alcatraz I got
done watching the episodes that are out
and I was like if I never see the show
again whatever odds are if you watch TV
and Alcatraz sounds like the kind of
intriguing show that you would like
you're probably watching or have watched
a show that's done intriguing better
than Alcatraz is doing so what's one of
your favorite shows currently airing on
TV right now that you're watching
canceled shows do not apply to this
question whatever it is comment below
let me know and as always if you like
what you've seen here and you want to
see more click right here to see more
you